folks welcome to rational science
you say why rational film isn't
all science rational well
[Music]
not science is rational
but not all theories out there are
rational
okay so let's separate those uh
here we have some criteria for what
rationality is we had to define
rationality because nobody has
okay not not in a scientific in a
formal way right so here we have a very
quick rundown
uh reifying concepts that's the worst
possible
scenario where someone wants to tell you
a theory
and he turns the spirit into a physical
entity okay
uh definitions a lot of people don't pay
attention to definitions uh certainly
no mathematician on planet earth pays
attention to
definitions they have no definitions uh
you know for the words that they're
going to use
uh to make their physical
interpretations
okay energy mass field none of those
words have ever been defined not in in
physical terms okay they've been defined
mathematically which
uh you know and then they use it as
physical objects again reification but
yeah they don't have definitions for
those terms
and that's what they make their case
with so you figure it out
theory must follow from the assumptions
you present a knife
at the trial and then you tell them that
the the deceased
died because of five bullets in his head
well it doesn't follow from the
assumption for what he presented right
describing instead of explaining that's
what mathematical physics does
all they can do is describe mathematics
can only describe mathematics
is a descriptive language it has no
power no
authority uh nowhere will to
to explain anything okay the explanation
is what
the mathematical physicists come in
there and say well we don't do that you
know
that's on the other side of campus
that's philosophy
but but that's what they they do
they try to give a physical
interpretation to the universe it's all
hogwash it's all nonsense and then they
cover it up by saying well we don't do
that anyway we do
equations and then the last one
unimaginable
mechanism that's what we're going to be
talking about today
that you cannot even imagine the
mechanism people propose
especially everybody out there
concerning
electricity the uh what is electricity
you know and
nobody can tell you uh not in a rational
way okay
so um because their mechanism
essentially is
unimaginable so what's different between
what the mathematicians do and what we
do here physics
you know we call ourselves rational
science rational physics
well i'll give you a little uh example
okay prepared a little
example and uh
what i want you to do is i i want you to
watch the little
film clip i'm gonna put here and then
i'm gonna ask you a question
about the film clip very simple question
okay just one question okay
and so here goes okay
let me show it to you one more time in
case you missed it
okay so here goes the million dollar
question okay
how did the window break what caused the
window to break
well if you're a rational individual if
you're a normal human being you would
say well you know
horseshoe went through the window very
simple very straightforward
it's a no-brainer okay
that's not what a mathematician would
answer
mathematician would answer this here let
me show you
this is how they would answer
well you see there was this mass and i
and he moved it with
all this energy and the force went
through the window
this is how a mathematician explains
physics
okay so he twirls a mass
using a lot of energy and the force goes
through the window
that's the difference between science
and what the mathematicians do
people who call themselves mathematical
physicists
what they do is uh they put all these
concepts and they use them as physical
objects
okay and yeah that's that's where the
problem is
we have a problem today in that all we
have are irrational explanations
primarily because
they reify they they turn
uh concepts into physical objects they
make them concrete
and they start moving around they don't
even realize it because it's part of
their language it's part of their jargon
and they've been doing this for the last
400 years maybe since the days of newton
you know and and so everybody just does
it casually they don't even realize what
they're doing and so when you point out
what do you mean by energy what do you
mean by mass and what do you mean by
field and what's
charge i didn't think uh
wave was a physical object i thought
wave was something that
something does you know and so on and so
this is the problem the problem is these
people don't even realize
that they're using concepts as physical
objects